what could people do if they have  interrupted sleep caffeine timing  definitely huge a lot of people don't  consider the half-life of caffeine is  five plus hours and depending on how old  you are your metabolism of the caffeine  gets worse and worse over time So  eventually it takes longer to work its  way out of your system in that afternoon  coffee that you had on top of your  morning coffee could be screwing you up  later into the night you just assume the  caffeine is not in your system because  you don't feel upbeat and energetic  anymore but in reality the residual  effects are still preventing you from  getting that really deep sleep